faut que j'écrive un truc vraiment
original t'as pas une idée tout aristote
un bon café
c'est ça le secret de la créativité
parce qu'avec un bon café
c'est pour ça que le café est si
important pour la créativité ce matin je
sais pas ce qui se passe j'ai vraiment
pas l'inspiration
bon j'en ai marre je vais juste pour b
aristote patois le philosophe celui 100h
près tout mais l'idée de culture
générale c'est un fait pour se prendre
la tête
les marais
c'est quoi le secret de la créativité
comment se fait-il que moi je sois
réduit à plagier aristote non pas toi
celui qui sans h le philosophe alors que
d'autres ont des idées géniales pour le
savoir j'ai lu récemment volé comme un
artiste en anglais ce style là qu'un
artiste de l'essayiste américain austin
green
comme d'habitude je vous permet de
télécharger mes notes de lecture en
cliquant sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite ou sur celui qui est dans
la description puis en me laissant votre
adresse email alors cet ouvrage c'est un
petit livre avec des dessins et beaucoup
de citations même sur kindle et ce petit
livre traitant révéler les dix secret
bien gardé sur la créativité génial tu
te rends compte aristote
finies les heures passées à brasser du
vent
fini les over dose de caféine fini
l'éternel plagiat d'aristote non pas toi
le philosophe celui sans h bon bah c'est
parti voyons voir lady secrets de la
créativité artistique temps arrêté
ça c'est quelque chose en réalité je
suis déjà créatif austin clients du site
le théologien william lynch qu'est-ce
que l'originalité un plagiat non
détectées qu'est-ce que j'étais naïf
moi je croyais les poètes grecs quand
ils disent que leur inspiration leur
vient des dieux je connaissais pourtant
la phrase de picasso les bons artistes
copient les grands artistes volent mais
de là à en faire le premier secret de la
créativité fondamentalement pour austin
claironne on s'inspire toujours de
quelqu'un a autant le faire consciemment
et du coup ça donne un nouveau regard
sur le monde
l'artiste qui assume la dimension
mimétique de son inspiration ne voit
plus le bien et le mal
ils voient des choses dignes d'être volé
et d'autres qui ne le sont pas la
créativité sa demande donc d'être très
pragmatique
d'abord tu trouves ce qui vaut la peine
d'être volé et christine clay homme puis
tu passe à autre chose
c'est à peu près tout ce qu'il ya à
faire ce premier secret repose sur le
fait que la nature humaine est
fondamentalement mimétique toute idée
que peu à voir l'artiste
quelqu'un l'a déjà eu sous une forme ou
une autre toute idée a donc une
généalogie l'enjeu de l'artiste
débutants c'est de remonter l'arbre
généalogique lorsqu'ils étudient ces
modèles pour ça il doit être très
curieux lire beaucoup prendre un maximum
de notes afin de garder le fruit de ses
vols pour plus tard austin cleon à lui
ce qu'il appelle un fichier mangue où il
conserve toutes les idées auxquelles il
voudra donner vie dans le futur
vous l'avez compris c'est ce premier
secret qui a donné son titre au livre
je veux rester 10 heures à mon bureau me
préparais 15 café l'originalité
authentique n'existe pas la clé de la
créativité
ce serait donc d'assumer et de cultiver
ses influences tu aurais voulu
l'arrêté
donc c'est bon je peux continuer à
plagier aristote non pas toi
le philosophe celui 100h mais en même
temps c'est pas moi c'est celle
philosophe qu'il ne faut pas nommer
aussi une clé ou de me dirais c'est pas
toi pour l'instant parce que je ne suis
pas censés voler uniquement le
philosophe qu'il ne faut pas donner il
faut que je multiplie les vols et ce
faisant je choisis les influences qui me
créer moi-même plus je vole plus
j'enrichis mon identité
le deuxième secret de la créativité
c'est donc de commencer sans se
connaître
parce que l'identité de l'artiste n'est
au sein même du processus artistique
il faut se débarrasser du syndrome de
l'imposteur parce que tout n'est qu'un
posture dans ce monde
des centaines de personnes ou plagiat
des centaines de personnes ont plagié le
philosophe qui ne faut pas nommés en
prétendant avoir leur propre originalité
austin claironne invite l'artiste en mal
de créativité à s'approprier la devise
de la silicon valley fake it to you make
m
le débutant doit prétendre être ce qui
n'est pas encore ou accomplir ce qu'il
n'a pas encore accomplie
là je dois dire que je suis assez
sceptique déjà ça me pose un problème
moral mais je vois surtout deux effets
pervers à cette philosophie
si on est trop à l'aise avec l'imposture
on risque de finir par s'en contenter et
de ne rien produire du tout et le
seconde effets pervers c'est qu'on peut
être pris sans le vouloir dans un espèce
s'est défait ponzi du mensonge
il faut mentir à nouveau pour conforter
le mensonge initial
et puis à zut il faut ensuite un
troisième
et puis un quatrième jusqu à bâtir
entièrement une oeuvre et une réputation
sur le mensonge
d'autres à mon humble avis la culture de
l'imposture
c'est risqué comme le montre d'ailleurs
certains scandales de la silicon valley
personnellement je préfère la
philosophie de la créativité de jack
london
pour réussir en tant qu'artiste mieux
vaut se sacrifier soi même au travail
plutôt que ces principes
mais au style crooner regagner mon
adhésion quand il précise ce qui
distingue l'inspiration mimétique du
plagiat l'artiste qui copiait son modèle
ne se contente pas de le copier
il s'approprie son style et sa vision du
monde dans le but de le dépasser
c'est à dire que l'imitation et celle
dans la créativité quand elle débouche
sur l'émulation par exemple le
basketteur kobe bryant a avoué avoir
entièrement puisé son répertoire
technique chez ses prédécesseurs mais il
a adapté les mouvements à sa morphologie
et il les a retravaillé pour essayer de
les améliorer
c'est donc en dépassant ses modèles avec
leur propre style qu'il est devenu kobe
bryant un des meilleurs joueurs de
l'histoire de la nba
ainsi c'est en volant que l'artiste
apprend puis devient lui-même personne
ne naît avec un style ou une voix écrit
austin claironne nous ne sortons pas du
ventre de notre mère en sachant qu'ils
nous sommes au début nous apprenons en
faisant semblant d'être nos héros nous
apprenons en copiant oui ma rétine
alors qu'il m'a fallu des heures pour
finalement décider de plagier philosophe
qui ne faut pas nommé austin claironne
lui raconte qu'il a écrit la suite du
film jurassic park comme ça en revenant
de la séance et il était enfant doué ce
qui l'attiré autant de créativité
est-ce qu'il se droguait déjà comme les
start up de la silicon valley ça on ne
sera pas son explication à lui c'est
tout simplement qu'il a écrit l'histoire
qu'il voulait lire il a simplement obéi
à sa pulsion créative et d'après lui ce
principe de créativité est valable pour
tout dessiner ce que vous voulez voir
démarrer l'entreprise que vous voulez
diriger jouer la musique vous voulez
entendre
écrivez les livres que vous voulez lire
construisez les produits que vous voulez
utiliser fait le travail que vous voulez
voir fait alors austin clé on n'explique
pas pourquoi il s'agit d'un bon principe
tout réussir mais c'est probablement que
notre propre désir de lire ce que l'on
s'apprête à écrire ce désir est
peut-être révélateur de l'existence
d'une base potentielle de lecteurs
l'expert en productivité de la silicon
valley tim ferriss dit que si on résout
un problème pour soi même la solution
pourrait probablement servir beaucoup
plus de monde
austin claironne préfère que l'écriture
reste un processus manuels parce que
d'après lui les mouvements du corps
favorise l'inspiration
après il garde un bureau digital et ils
passent successivement de son bureau
manuel à son bureau digital s'il se
méfie de l'ordinateur c'est parce qu'il
trouve qu'il nuit à sa créativité en le
coupant de son environnement
il souligne aussi que la facilité a
édité le contenu avec un ordinateur ou
favorise le perfectionnisme mais là j'ai
du mal à le suivre
facilité l'édition du contenu c'est
faciliter son amélioration
donc c'est plutôt en faveur du projet de
l'arnon il aurait mieux fait de parler
de l'effet des animaux de compagnie sur
la créativité
austin clé elle prend ses distances avec
le premier précepte de la productivité
la concentration ou le focus
en anglais on dit généralement qu'il
faut concentrer toutes ses forces sur un
projet unique et on comprend bien
pourquoi avec ce petit schéma mais pour
austin claironne il ne faut pas
s'interdire des projets annexes
il ne faut pas abandonner ses passions
parce que la magie de la créativité
opère en réalité dans l'interaction
entre le projet principal est ce qu'il
ya autour lui par exemple attend avoir
boosté sa créativité en reprenant la
musique
là encore une fois je ne suis pas
convaincu je peux comprendre le principe
mais je ne crois pas que ça soit un
super conseil à notre époque où la
dispersion est en train de devenir une
vraie maladie
et puis dans l'absolu il reste la
question du temps si on empile les
projets on va avancer trop lentement
dans chacun d'entre eux austin claironne
prône également ce qu'il appelle la
procrastination productive c'est à dire
perdre volontairement du temps par
exemple en repassant en faisant la
vaisselle en marchant ou en se perdant
dans ses pensées pour accélérer la
fermentation des idées là je suis plutôt
d'accord avec lui mais je trouve qu'il
ne s'agit pas véritablement de
procrastination mais tout simplement de
la nécessité faire des pauses bref je
suis assez sceptique en ce qui concerne
ce cinquième secret en revanche j'adhère
totalement au suivant j'aurais voulu
l'arrêté
[Musique]
ouf
vous êtes encore là j'ai de la chance si
vous êtes encore là parce que
l'attention du public est très difficile
à gagner
les gens n'ont pas de temps à consacrer
à l'oeuvre de l'artiste
du coup le retour à la réalité peut être
difficile après les fantasmes du départ
mais l'absence de public est aussi une
opportunité comme presque personne ne va
juger le travail du débutant
il a la possibilité il a même intérêt à
essayer différentes choses
de toute façon le processus créatif suit
généralement les mêmes phases où
commence le projet en pensant que c'est
une idée géniale on arrive à un état
quasi dépressif
puis ils ont fini par produire quelque
chose de moins bien que prévu mais de
pas si mal quand même
aujourd'hui il faut toujours travailler
aussi dur mais une chose a changé grâce
à internet il est beaucoup plus facile
de diffuser son travail austin clown
conseille donc de développer une
relation avec son public de le raconter
sa vie de lui dévoiler les coulisses des
projets et plus généralement de se
familiariser avec les nouvelles
solutions qui permettent de partager le
travail artistique
après internet accroît aussi la
confiance donc le débutant n'a pas le
choix il doit miser sur la qualité pour
sortir du lot le 6ème conseil est donc
fait du bon travail
puis partagé le marais
austin claironne vite à austin texas
ah non ça n'est pas une blague austin
vite à austin donc c'est là qu'il est la
plupart du temps et pourtant il estime
que sa ville compte pour moins de 10% de
son inspiration
les 90 autres % viennent d'ailleurs du
monde entier en fait parce que ces
modèles sont éparpillés un peu partout
grâce à internet ils voyagent
mentalement et il customise son bureau
pour cultiver cette forme d'inspiration
de temps en temps il fait aussi de vrais
voyages où ils se déplacent matériel les
voyages ont un effet bénéfique sur la
créativité parce qu'ils sortent
l'artiste de sa zone de confort
géographique et ce faisant il le pousse
se confronter au nouveau remettre en
cause sa vision du monde
en particulier ils lui permettent de
rencontrer des artistes plus talentueux
que lui qui le tire vers le bas ça c'est
crucial d'après austin clown parce que
sans émulation
on ne progresse pas si jamais il s'avère
que vous êtes la personne la plus
talentueuse de la pièce vous devez en
trouver une autre
mais ce n'est pas une raison pour être
malveillant avec les artistes moins
talentueux marais
déjà que le monde est petit mais à
l'heure d'internet c'est pire tout se
sait et les traces sont presque
indélébile un tweet un contrôle et un
commentaire impulsif et une réputation
peut être entachée à jamais voici donc
la règle d'austin claironne rester
bienveillante et ignorer que c'est le
secret à cet égard c'est de rediriger
ses pulsions négative vers la créativité
de travailler dur encore plus dure avec
l'énergie des pulsions négative sans
attendre passivement une confirmation
extérieur soyez à l'aise avec le fait
d'être mal compris dénigrer ou ignorés
l'astuce consiste à être trop occupé à
faire votre travail pour vous en souci
en revanche si vous recevez des
compliments vous avez intérêt à essayer
de prolonger l'énergie le surcroît de
motivation qui vous procure par exemple
au style clé on met de côté tous les
avis positifs qu'il reçoit pour en
retrouver l'effet dynamogène quand il en
aura besoin
quant aux avis négatif il fait comme
s'il n'existait pas moi je ne suis pas
cette règle donc si vous avez envie de
me critiquer dans les commentaires
sentez vous libre de le faire je
laisserais votre commentaire et je
répondrai du mieux que je peux si ça
peut me rendre plus créatifs corrèze
un arrêté
bon ça 9e secret n'en est pas vraiment
un
pour réussir en tant qu'artiste il faut
travailler à d'accord alors reçu john ne
le présente pas comme ça il dit être
ennuyeux mais si le quotidien de
l'artiste est entre guillemets ennuyeux
c'est parce qu'on ne peut pas produire
une oeuvre dans la piscine d'une villa
ou en descendant les pistes sur un
snowboard
sinon il faut prendre des [ __ ] comme
les hommes politiques mais je ne pense
pas que les hommes politiques
revendiquent eux le statut d'artiste
même s'ils peuvent l'être à leur manière
ce 9e secret c'est plus précisément
qu'il faut organiser son quotidien et
formater son environnement pour
favoriser la régularité du travail
j'aime beaucoup la citation de flaubert
que donne austin club soyez régulier et
ordonnée dans votre vie comme un
bourgeois
ainsi vous pouvez vous être emportés et
originale dans votre oeuvre
c'est une évidence mais on n'écrit pas à
guéret paix en boîte de nuit
le génie romantique drogués en
permanence et qui meurent au sommet de
son art c'est un fantasme parce que la
créativité consomment trop d'énergie
pour que l'artiste lagache par ailleurs
c'est pour ça que le débutant a intérêt
à être économe comme un petit bourgeois
afin que d'éventuels soucis financiers
ne le détourne pas de son oeuvre
austin clé on lui conseille comme jack
london de se trouver un job alimentaire
c'est la garantie de sa liberté
artistique sauf s'il écrit des poèmes
contre son patron mais m il peut faire
tout le reste c'est aussi la garantie
d'une vie sociale
ça peut être une source d'inspiration et
enfin ça lui impose une routine
paradoxalement un job alimentaire peut
même le rendre plus régulier dans le
travail parce que ça le contraint à
tirer le maximum du temps restant ça
c'est la fameuse loi de parkinson si
vous avez quatre heures pour écrire
mille mots vous allez avoir tendance à
produire ce quota bilan quatre heures et
le second davantage de la régularité
auquel fait référence austin claironne
c'est l'effet cumulé la constitution du
neuf ou la construction
une carrière est en grande partie liée à
la lente accumulation de petits bouts et
fort au fil du temps écrire une page
chaque jour on ne semble pas beaucoup
mais faites-le pendant 365 jours et vous
avez assez pour remplir un roman petit
conseil pratique d'austin claironne pour
supporter l'accumulation de ces petits
bouts d'efforts munissez vous d'un
calendrier dédié et d'un journal de bord
bon c'est pas très sexy tout ça on est
pas dans californication austin clients
de reconnaît d'ailleurs que l'ennui du
quotidien de l'écrivain risque aussi de
contaminer sa vie de couple
[Musique]
ça c'est un vrai secret la créativité
artistique augmente par soustraction
[Musique]
plus le processus créatif est simple
plus il sera efficace ans l'artiste se
disperse meilleures seront les résultats
ça c'est quand même en contradiction
avec le secret d'une roue 5
vous serez cultiver une certaine
dispersion austin claironne parle
surtout de l'importance de la
soustraction à propos de l'information
comme nous vivons dans une société où
l'information est excessivement
abondante ce qui est de la valeur
désormais c'est le traitement de
l'information
à commencer par sélection mais ce secret
de la soustraction s'applique de manière
beaucoup plus général ça s'appelle la
vie à négative à cette idée évoquée
notamment par nassim taleb dans son
essai anti fragile signifie que tout
processus se perfectionne par la
simplification
c'est peut-être celui ci le secret
crucial de la liste d'austin tm vous
voulez être plus créatif fait simple
pour faire mieux rester dans les limites
de la simplicité
les artistes qui réussissent savent ce
que leur créativité doit aux contraintes
c'est paradoxalement du combat contre
leurs propres limites qu'elle mais leur
offre
voici donc les 10 secrets de la
créativité des artistes et en
particulier des écrivains qui
réussissent copier les autres artistes
commencé sans se connaître et écrire ce
que l'on veut lire utiliser ses mains
plutôt que de tout faire l'ordinateur
cultiver une certaine dispersion
diffuser un travail de qualité
voyager en esprit en bref restez
bienveillant assumer d'être ennuyeux et
enfin simplifier le processus créatif
alors vous l'avez compris je ne suis pas
d'accord avec tout je ne suis pas un
artiste du coup encore moins un qui a
réussi mais je suis sceptique à l'égard
du fake it till you make it
la devise de la silicon valley de la
préférence pour les processus manuels et
de l'encouragement aux projets annexes
en revanche je suis convaincue par les
trois secrets qui sont à mes yeux les
plus importants ce qu'austin clé on
appelle voler les autres artistes même
s'il a expliqué la nuance avec le
plagiaire le fait d'écrire ce qu'on
voudrait lire un principe que j'ai déjà
lu ou entendu par ailleurs et enfin je l
ai déjà dit la vie à négative à soi la
nécessité de simplifier le processus
créatif mais bon le principe fondamental
du livre c'est bien voler comme un
artiste
l'artiste qui a réussi est un plagiaire
curieux méthodique et ambitieux le
débutant en quête d'authenticité lui
attendra longtemps ceux qui ne veulent
rien limites et ne produisent rien
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo jusqu'au
bout si vous voulez décuplé ma
créativité donner un pouce vu la vidéo
et puis abonnez-vous à la chaîne si vous
aimez la vulgarisation de la pensée et
enfin laisser un petit commentaire et je
vous promets de rester bienveillant
comme le recommande
austin claironne instant vous ignorent
jeu vous permet aussi de télécharger mes
notes de lecture et si vous voulez lire
ma synthèse écrite détaillée de voler
comme un artiste qui sur le blog ou si
vous souhaitez lire l'essai directement
tous les liens sont dans la description
je suis romain je suis avec mon fidèle
aristote balle philosophe le chihuahua
et vous étiez sur mille idées de culture
générale vous n'avez pas besoin de
plagier qui que ce soit pour vous
intéresser au meilleur de la pensée sans
vous prendre la tête
[Musique]